If everyone
you ever loved suddenly started dying
and turning into flesh eating monsters,
what would you do?
You're trapped on a spaceship
and no one is coming to save you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes, mate.
What you should do and how to beat
the necromorphs in dead space.
These resource colonist wannabes have no idea
they are all about to die.
These guys are deep space
mining this giant rock when they come across
something sinister as hell.
This massive structure, known
throughout their galaxy as a marker, an alien
artifact of unknown origin worshiped by a
cult like group back on Earth known as Unity
Allergists, these scientists
then let the base know that they found
a second marker artifact,
just like the one back on Earth,
and they left their space station.
Take it back for testing.
Little do they realize that
bringing this marker back with them
will be the end for everyone on this planet.
This is insane.
We've just found the second marker
ever in existence like this is a huge deal.
Now we know a little bit about it
based on the religious text,
but the fact that we found this
on a dead planet with markings
everywhere like someone has been here before,
means that I think twice before
bringing this artifact back home with us,
we still know very little about it.
We do know, however, for a fact
that this thing gives off extremely dangerous
hallucinations to almost everybody,
which means that this marker is more deadly
than we think they need to start treating
this thing like a psychotropic weapon
with capabilities
to infect every living thing at close range.
I mean, look at it, these guys have no idea
what they're getting themselves into,
and based on their reactions
are unprepared as hell to handle this thing
and it'll cost them.
But there's one thing even bigger
than the marker that'll have you wish
you knew so much more about,
and that is our sponsor for today's video .
Skillshare Skillshare is amazing.
I've been on there for a solid few weeks,
and this is nothing like I had growing up.
Like, Seriously.
There's two teachers
that I really enjoyed learning from,
and that is Donald Fittsgill and Erin Lillis.
Skillshare has so much to offer for newbies
and seasoned pros like myself.
There's something for everyone.
Acting classes, audio
editing, writing, marketing and so much more.
So whatever it is,
you're interested in learning more about.
Go to Skillshare.
They can help
you make 2022 a year of new learning
growth through connection and creativity.
So if you want to be the next great anime
drawing artist or guy video editing guy,
whatever it is that you want to be.
Go to Skillshare and level up your game.
Invest in yourself
because the first 1000 people
who use this link will get a one month free
trial of Skillshare.
How amazing is that?
And thank you, Skillshare,
for sponsoring this video.
This horrifying alien marker
is then taken back to the Planet station,
where it is held in waiting,
waiting for a ship known as the Shimura
to take this artifact back home to Earth.
But this is just the beginning.
Over the next month,
savage violence begins taking place
among crew members on the Planet station,
just as the Ishimura reaches the planet
in time for the Marker's extraction.
However, some station crew members
like this guy think this thing is cursed
and that this very artifact
is the cause of all the murders recently.
Too bad everyone else thinks
this is all pure coincidence.
Everyone except that guy and this girl
named Alyssa, chief of the ship's security,
who heads to the captain and informs him
that she doesn't think the marker
should remain on this ship
for transport any longer.
Because ever since they brought the marker
onto the Ishimura, the same optics
and crew violence that happened on the planet
station started happening again
on the ship the very same day
they brought that marker on board.
But the captain thinks she's crazy and blames
all of the murders and violence
due to deep space fatigue, which is a cause
from being in space too long.
Unless I think it's mad and wonders
why this thing is so important,
but the captain assures her that once
his scientists studies it,
then she'll be able to do a full analysis.
OK, I have a question one
why won't the captain let the chief
security officer do a full analysis
first before the scientist?
Safety first, anyone.
But while the captain may seem like he's
taking this too lightly,
he does have a point about the crew
having deep space fatigue
because the reality is space
flight puts an exorbitant amount of stress
on the body, not to mention the high stress
work environment and consistent pressure
to perform without fault.
And that puts space workers at all
sorts of risks of developing emotional stress
with astronauts, for example,
having an average of three to 58% chance
of developing post-traumatic stress disorder
from simply being in space
compared to the one to 14% chance
that the general public
on Earth, half of developing PTSD.
And with this comes an 84%
chance of alcoholism.
42% chance of drug abuse.
68% chance of depression and 26% chance
of antisocial personality disorder.
And did I also mention that the Ishimura ship
has been in space for already two years?
That means that the chances for on orbit
and post
spaceflight psychiatric issues
jump up exponentially.
In short, folks.
It's a huge coincidence that all these deaths
began to occur
as soon as that marker was brought in.
But we can't deny that people
who have been in space for too long
have a way higher
likelihood of losing their minds.
And we got to take this into account first
before blaming it
on outside forces right outside of the ship.
The Ishimura
then gets ready to crack this planet,
a process done
to deplete a planet's resources.
Because of this, a massive gravity raid
then beams down onto the planet,
pulling an entire segment of the planet's
crust right off.
And this monolith of rock begins
ascending high into the sky,
and we get to see the menacing nature
of humanity's future potential.
Back on the Ishimura, these doctors
try to get to the bottom of why passengers
have suddenly started going insane,
and this crazy guy
then mentions that he needed to kill
because they need bodies to turn.
But this doctor has no idea
what the hell he's talking about
and thinks he's crazy blaming
his hallucinations on the meds he's taking.
Then this doctor comes in and asks
What the hell is going on?
But the nurse says that
she's already gave him enough sleeping meds
to put down a horse
around 500 cc's of anesthesia .
Something is keeping him awake,
and it's sure not the medicine.
The doctor and the nurse eventually managed
to put him back to sleep,
and he walks outside to find even more
lettuce, fresh corpses surrounding him.
He knows something is going on. But what?
This is insane. Think about it.
This guy is way past
any normal dose of anesthesia, around
5000 milligrams, which is about 1000 times
over the average dose of anesthetic.
This means that either
this man weighs about 400 kilograms
or something within his central nervous
system is simply overpowering his state
of being because he should be out cold
if not dead, with that much
sleeping drugs in his system as a doctor.
This would be outside of the realm
of medical science, and I wouldn't overlook
the subtle signs that something
is seriously wrong with this guy.
And the problem is
this guy was fine and normal a week ago,
and in that time has gone from normal
to full on local and murderous.
Now, unless he experienced a severe
bout of emotional stress or trauma, head
injury, stroke, tumors or something,
I don't see how this man could go insane
in that short of a time span, as mental cases
usually come about in stages and over time.
Also, the fact that multiple people
just like him have started to go insane
all of a sudden out of nowhere
is beyond coincidence.
Now I get it. We're in space.
You can go a little nuts.
But how is it that people by the dozen
are all acting the same way right now?
Because we know for a fact
that the marker causes hallucinations,
which means that these medically trained
professionals need to start looking
at the obvious signs
that something is about to go down
on the Ishimura
and maybe consider abandon ship.
The doctor escorts another corpse into a room
full of dead
bodies covered under crisp, blood
soaked white blankets,
filling yet another room of victims
victims of what soon to come.
Just then, a massive rumble hits the ship,
causing concern with everybody on it.
But the captain assures them
that it is normal electromagnetic surges
caused by this planet's
magnetic field bleeding out,
and they continue to extract resources
from this chunk of rock,
arousing more fear than curiosity
among the concerned ship crew.
Who knows this time
something doesn't feel right,
but then all of a sudden, another
massive rumbling this time
bigger than the last one erupts
across the entire ship, violently
shaking everything
and everyone, causing the captain to let out
a little more fear in his reassuring words
than he'd like.
The crew doesn't know what's going on
and thinks something is wrong with the ship.
A temporary glitch.
Perhaps the captain then orders the ship
to make contact with the colony
back on the planet, but the crew mentions
that the signal is choppy.
Ilesa and bald guy here
think that something from somewhere
is intentionally cutting off their signal,
but the crew laughs in her face.
The ship finally makes contact
with the planet's station and are told
that the surface is not doing much better
with the entire land violently shaking.
Thinking all of this
to be the cause from the rock
that they extract it
being too close to the planet's core.
But this pilot's back on the planet
doesn't have time, because all of a sudden
he sees the captain's call on the screen
turn into a horrifying monster.
He's losing his mind, and he's not
the only one finally landing at the station.
These two guys exit the vehicle,
but just then they noticed that something's.
Sinister is going on.
The station is empty, filled with nothing but
thick slime webbing and wall hugging vines.
It looks like nobody's been here in 50 years,
but that's impossible.
This guy thinks that something is off
and parts ways with his doomed
copilot walking past a hallway
when he suddenly hears distant screams,
followed by a horrifying bellowing roar
coming from something terrifying.
He begins to run for his life, passing
more and more dead corpses
until he finally reaches his room.
But this room is like all the rest
covered an absolute mess and blood.
This man desperately calls for his wife, but
she's nowhere to be found in the distance.
This man hears some noise and his eyes widen.
He sees his wife covered in blood
and carrying an energized weapon,
uttering the same words
as the prisoner back on the Ishimura.
They want our bodies tearing at her own body.
She finally does
the nasty and half slices her head off dead.
I guess the marriage
was too much for her to bear.
OK, this guy may be a good husband,
but he's a bad human.
It's safe to say that 500 years in the future
when all of this takes place,
that we as humans by
then would be even more familiar
with the classic horror tropes
that are out and about.
From the eerie, empty rooms
to faint screams and monster roars
from creatures that he doesn't see.
Not to mention the bloodstained room
and signs of the marker in his own house.
This man should have known that something
not ordinary was about to happen
and should have been more prepared
than he was for what's to come.
Also, our wife just cut her own head
almost off.
She is literally dead weight.
I wouldn't stick around to mourn
her much, and I would leave
and get to the space station
as soon as possible.
Now, we don't know for sure where exactly
this guy is, but if nearby, I would stop
at the control room barracks if it was close
enough first before grabbing weaponry.
Because let's be honest, this guy knew
there was something evil down here
the moment he and us heard those terrifying
alien screams in the distance.
So if he knows what's good for him,
he'll arm up and get the hell out of there.
Back on the ship, the doctor tells the
captain that his last analysis on the marker
revealed a large psychosomatic energy field
unlike any other he's ever seen.
But the captain still thinks
that the energy field that's heading
the ship is coming from the planet
and not the marker.
The captain has gone way past denial
and is now fast approaching suicidal.
But just then, the ship
finally gets in contact
with the security cameras
placed on the station back at the planet,
and everybody in the room finally sees
the horrors that are going on down there.
Dead bodies everywhere, blood painted
on the walls and no one alive in sight.
Alyssa
then demands that they sent a security team
back to the planet when all of a sudden
the onboard assistant reveals
that she's getting multiple flat
lines of everybody on the planet colony.
More people are dying
and the screen turns blood red.
They are being slaughtered, but by what?
Meanwhile, back on the planet,
this dude with his wife in his arms
is running away from his room, running
towards the same ship that he entered in.
As he rests his wife down and starts
the ship's thrusters,
something flies into the ship
right in the nick of time,
and now his ship is on a course
back to the issue.
Mura the horror show has just begun,
and everybody on board
finally finds out that something back on
the planet is attacking them.
And this guy says that something is killing
all of his men,
saying that something is down there with them
until we hear a horrifying roar
and the calm is cut off.
Alyssa has had enough
and so has the doc, and he alerts the captain
that they need
to send in reinforcements ASAP.
But the captain has been a bad boy
and no one can find out where they are.
Thanks to his illegal drilling operation
on this
planet's surface, and he demands the doc
to keep his mouth shut.
What's going on here is nothing like what
the religious texts suggest,
and the dark begs the captain
to at least inform the unit's largest church
about what's going on.
But the captain apparently doesn't care
and is more worried about his crew,
who most are either
part of the religious church
or are sympathizers
with the unit's largest cause.
He cannot afford a mutiny on his ship
and sets course
to abandon the planet colony
and head straight for Earth.
He can't let anyone from the planet colony
back on this ship because he knows what.
I'm pretty sure all of you now know everybody
on the planet colony is about to die.
Suddenly,
they are alerted to an incoming ship.
It's the guy and his wife,
and they're headed straight for the Ishimura,
a of demands
that they let the incoming ship on board.
But the captain puts on his big boy voice
and orders the ship to go on lockdown now.
OK, if I was the captain, I would agree.
The unit's largest religion
has spread far and wide among everybody,
and we know just how dangerous some religious
fanatics are and how far they're.
Willing to go for a cost.
And judging from the Marker's prominence
and the fact that this entire mission
is funded by the unity largest church itself,
we might get some pushback
if we tell our crew something
they don't like.
And based on the history of ship
mutinies over time.
The act of ship mutiny
particularly means that open rebellion
against the captain of the ship
the highest in command,
which means we would be screwed
if we don't play our cards right.
And to top this off, we have a ship coming
straight from the tainted planet itself
as stone cold as it is.
We should probably do what
the captain is saying, because if we don't,
this incoming ship
could be the start of a major outbreak,
which is why we're better off
locking down the ship and preventing the
likely infectious disease that is on board
that ship from entering Ares.
But if they do enter our ship,
the ship should already have in place
measures to quarantine and isolate
incoming vessels from the jump.
This is going to be able to help
protect the crew and everybody on board
the ship and help prevent exposure
to whatever it is that is out there,
including the closure of all ventilation
systems present on the landing dock.
So even if this ship makes it in,
they should not be too big of concern
if they set everything up
right back on the incoming ship,
the guy pilots the hell out of his cruiser,
refusing orders to stand down
just as his corpse of a wife comes back
from the dead and tears into his face.
The captain forces
all entrances on the ship to close,
but the incoming ship
just manages to sneak through one open
pod bay door and the ship comes crashing down
onto the landing pad.
It's go time
Melissa and her security crew are ordered
to go down there and secure and quarantine.
Whatever the hell is on that ship, suiting up
and bearing some space clocks.
The security team approaches the ship with
caution, but something is not right with it.
As they slowly enter the crashed ship,
they witnessed the horrors of nothing.
The ship is empty,
except there is blood everywhere.
Whatever was on board has slipped on through.
They come across a hole
at the front of a ship with trail markings
leading out of the ship.
It's official something is now on board
the Ishimura, the team
that moves out, hoping to find the source
of all this horror before it's too late.
Back in the quarantined lab, the crazy
prisoner wakes up to a star terrified
of what he thinks he knows is going on,
and something passes by him in the distance.
He heads out barefoot past the doors
and right into a pile of blood,blood
leading right into the morgue.
And this crazy prisoner proves
that he's stupid enough
to ignore the warning
signs and heads into the morgue.
He comes across piles and piles of body parts
and corpses
covered in bloody goo,
and that's when he sees it in the distance.
The most horrifying winged creature
slicing into the forehead of a corpse,
injecting it with something that then turns
this body into the most terrifying thing
this crazy prisoner has ever seen
a murderous DNA altered space Necromorph
and they come straight for this guy's throat
and the space prisoner
tail coats the hell out of there
faster than the wind god Hanuman himself.
But these Necromorphs are too quick
for their own good and stab him
right through the gut, forcing him
to come face to face with this competitor.
Eater
looking alien monster ripping him to shreds.
OK, if I was a prisoner on the ship,
I would have been way more cautious
before exiting that room.
I would have at least taken
some weaponry or sedatives with me
in case anybody tried to arrest me.
But also you just saw for himself
blood on the floor and chose to head
to the dumbest place one could go
in a scary situation like this the morgue.
This takes place 500 years in the future.
Hasn't anyone ever heard of every horror
trope ever?
It's obvious
we know by now that something is going
on, and due to the Ishimori insane
ventilation system, we stand no chance
against whatever these things are due
to the fact that they can reach us in
almost any part of the ship once again,
thanks to the damp ventilation systems.
I would say screw the morgue
and go to arguably
the most protected parts of the ship.
I would either head down towards the mining
deck, the medical bay or the bridge,
maybe not the medical.
If the cases down there have begun to surge
because these are the parts of the ship
that will be the most heavily secured.
I would also find some change of clothes
along the way to pass off
as a harmless passenger, but in any case,
when it all goes to hell and it will.
I doubt anyone will care
that my fake identity is not on the passenger
manifest in the main control room.
This glasses guy lets the captain know
that it's official.
They've lost all contact with the planet
colony, and the doc thinks that
the captain needs to let someone on Earth
know just what the hell is going on here .
But the captain yet again
refuses, ordering the dock
to go down to check on the marker
in other areas of the ship.
A crowd is gathering right in front of where
the proclaimed
a marker is causing security
around it to tighten.
They suspect that something is going on,
and it's all because
of the one thing
that they believe in the marker itself.
The dark arrives just as the workers
get rowdy, but this unit's allergist
believe in Ponytail Guy here tells.
The doc that he can help calm everyone down,
and he eases the heightened tensions
that everyone is feeling at a sense,
the angered crowds away from the marker
easing what everybody knows on the ship
knows yet that they are all about to die.
The duck, while studying the marker, suddenly
looks up and sees this horrifying corpse.
Or does he back at the morgue?
Alice's team reaches the gore filled room,
finding nothing yet again
except the rummages of monsters
who were once there.
20 corpses suddenly gone,
and there's not a single one in this room.
Alyssa then caused this end to the captain.
Just as this Necromorph
wakes up right behind this guy,
throwing him to the floor
and gnawing at his flesh.
Alissa gets the thing off of him,
and the crew joins in to help
flinging the Beast away from them.
But another one pops up before the team
blasts it into oblivion.
The gang wonders Just what the hell is this?
Just as the captain radios in, but another
monster comes in and is blasted in the face,
Alyssa has had enough and ordered the team
to secure the room and move on.
Nobody has any idea what's going on
except the ship's doc, who tells the captain
All of this is connected to the alien marker.
What are they doing?
We know that this thing on
the ship is an infection of sorts,
and as with any infection,
the goal is to spread to convert more hosts
and to spread the infection even further.
And from what we've seen,
it doesn't look like the infection
can be spread through bites or scratches.
It seems like the only way to spread
is through death
that these things can be reanimated
into the creatures that we now know.
But at this point, it's
safe to say that the infection
is spreading faster than we can contain it.
So our best bet would be to monitor
and defend all key parts of the ship
vital to the continuing operation
of managing the Ishimura.
Depending on how many men
we have in total on our security team,
I would stationed them at the engineering
deck, the hydroponics deck,
which is necessary for the sustained
production of the ship's oxygen.
I would also place men at the medical deck.
The computer core will be able to control
remotely, locking down and unlocking
various areas.
I would also play some guys
at the tram system, the filtration system
and the captain's bridge.
Doing this will be easier than running
wild on a goose chase,
trying to catch
whatever is already on the loose.
The doctor is right.
The markers influence
has taken over the whole ship
and is turning everybody into horrifying
natural morphs that hunt down
and turn dead humans into alien
like creatures.
There's no stopping these things now.
The captain and crew see the horrors
that plagued the ship, and the captain
sounds off the alarm, sending Alyssa
to the mess hall to put a final stop to this.
But it's too late.
The mess hall is littered with corpses,
and even worse, this army of feeding
Necromorphs Alyssa and her crew
fire at the incoming army,
who quickly overwhelm
all of them and knock down a few key members,
causing them
to fight these demons at close range.
The Negro morphs have knocked over
muscles, guy knocking this guy over
and biting this blond guy repeatedly.
Alyssa knows they're outmatched,
and she sees Muscle Guy get decapitated
right in front of her, with soul patch guy
about to get ripped to
shreds till suddenly Ponytail
Guy comes in hot and saves them all.
Alyssa,
thanks Ponytail Guy for saving their asses,
and the gang goes
to collect the very same weapon
that this unit's pledges to love
and fanatic is rocking a lizard contacts
the pilot room where the captain is,
but no response.
This blond guy then says that they need
to get the hell out of there.
But too bad Alyssa is too goody two shoes
to listen and says that they need to save
as many people as they can on the ship
first before anything else happens.
Honestly, why doesn't a lizard just think
about the reality of the situation?
We're a small crew.
We do not know much about these
natural morphs.
We're now going to be able to save many,
if at all.
How about we just listen
to blond a douche bag over here
because there's no way that we can stop
all of this.
I would ask Ponytail Guy
where he got his weapon from and suit up
because screw saving everyone here.
Melissa and her crew
need to start thinking for themselves,
and I would start by escorting them
near the control room and flight room,
specifically the captain's nest.
Because right near
there is the one thing that'll guarantee
we'll live to fight another day.
And that is, dare
I say, the escape pods, which are right
next to the captain's observation area.
I say, screw the Ishimura,
let's save our crew and get out of there.
Alyssa and her crew
then team up with Ponytail Guy
and the gang prepares
to head back to the pilot room.
At the pilot room, the staff alerts
the captain that they've lost communication
with everybody on the ship,
and this causes the captain to sweat bullets.
He orders the team to lock down
all areas of the ship
and plotted course for Earth immediately.
However, the doc finally has had enough
and argues
with the captain that they both know
that the marker is a trap.
They need to get rid of it.
But the captain demands
that the marker to be delivered to the church
if humanity is to have any chance of being
welcomed at the universal awakening
and that's when it finally hits,
the captain has clearly lost his mind,
and now the doc knows
and so do all the crew members.
The doc thinks the marker is causing
the captain to be paranoid and delusional.
And the captain demands
that the dock be arrested, but the crew
has had enough of the captain's insane orders
and try to arrest him instead.
The dock tries to get in on psychotic fun
and tries to stick the captain
with a sedative, but misses
and stabs his eye, killing the captain.
Whatever he's doing
has cut every single person on this ship
off from the rest of humanity,
and now everyone knows it.
And just then the ship ejects
every single emergency pod
that the ship has into space,
forcing everyone to now be stranded
and at the mercy of the icy moura's
horrifying demise.
Whatever is doing,
all of this has cut every single person
on this ship off from the rest of humanity,
and now everyone knows it all.
Emergency shuttles
have now gone deep into space.
Back at Alice's Group, the gang comes across
more horrifying natural morphs that
send the gang running into the utility lift
and through these giant blast doors.
But something is wrong with blond hair
guy and Alissa notices.
Blond Hair Guy claims it's nothing as
they entered this expansive vegetation room.
Alyssa then asks Bald Guy
to keep an eye on blond guy,
but he's too insane to keep under control.
Forcing blue haired girl to knock him down.
But then he begins, muttering
the same words that the psycho prisoner
from earlier set
claiming that they want our bodies.
Just then, this giant Necromorph
pops out and tries to attack blue haired girl
and the Gang X, quickly
slicing off all of its limbs
and its baby little monsters left and right.
But there's too many of them.
More and more Necromorphs
come charging at everyone, slicing limbs left
and right and blood spurts everywhere.
Blond Guy even manages to slice blue hair
girl Hannibal style and charges at Alyssa.
Blond Guy has officially lost his mind
before he gets shot in the head by Bald Guy.
They know that it's official the marker
is making everyone lose their minds.
Either they will all be killed by these Negro
morphs, or they will kill each other
back at the bridge.
With the captain dead
and having lost control of the ship,
the crew thinks hard of what to do next.
There's no way to contact Earth
and no escape off of the ship itself,
and it's only a matter of time
until the monsters come in here to get them.
Suddenly, they lose power and hear hard
hitting rumbles at the front door.
The doors finally open up,
but luckily it's Alyssa and her crew.
The crew tells Alyssa
that the captain is dead
and that they can't reach anyone on the comm,
nor can also reach the rest of her squads.
But just then, a huge alarm
sounds off, and the guidance computer
holding the ship up in orbit loses power.
The issue Mora is now slowly falling
out of orbit, being pulled by the planet,
and if they don't do anything soon,
they will all come crashing down
into the planet itself.
The crew
then finds out that the person meddling with
the ship's
function is none other than the doc himself.
Alyssa demands that they try and stop him
putting everyone else's safety above hers,
and the crew heads out to find the dock
as they roam the corpse filled hallways.
Alyssa then hears panicked screams and finds
some people trapped in a room
waiting to be eaten and skinned alive
by these, Necromorphs ponytail guy
then sacks up and distracts the monsters
as Alyssa sneaks in through the vent shaft
to help the trapped passengers
saving countless lives.
But losing ponytail guy as he fights
these knuckle morphs to the death.
Alyssa and her final team, bald guy,
reached the computer room where the doc is
as he tries to bypass the locks,
causing the attention of more horrifying
neck morphs to head their way.
But they don't have enough time.
So like all his comrades before him, bald guy
sacrifices himself to save Alyssa,
allowing her to catch the dark
red handed and knocks him back,
getting into a tussle between the two.
The doc, being the man of Science, says
that he thinks the infection is too dangerous
and that everyone on the ship
all needs to die to ultimately save humanity
from catching this plague.
But a being the badass babe that she is?
Refuses to give up and beats him the hell up
before stabilizing the ship.
But the doc runs off and it's not over
because she's beginning to feel the effects
of the marker, too.
And it's only a matter of time
before she turns into one of them
unable to reach anyone.
Alyssa
then reaches the place where it all began.
The marker itself, just as she sees
an army of Necromorphs coming for her.
She runs with all of her
might about to die until the Necromorphs.
Stop chasing her.
It seems as though the marker
is preventing them from getting too close,
but she's not out of the woods yet
because Alyssa passes out.
OK, you know what?
We might be in a good situation right now
because we found the only spot
on the entire ship where these flesh
eating bastards can't get us.
So I say, let's take it slow and use
whatever we have to make the most of it.
Everyone is dead, and the mission has failed,
arguably in every possible way.
But we do have one thing on our side
and that is the miraculous feats
of the human body itself.
The human body can survive for up
to two months without any food,
but only up to four days without any water.
If we're stuck here for the long haul,
I would say waited out until help comes.
If ever it's a long shot,
I know I'd say kick back for a few hours
and let the initial appeal of ourselves
towards the neck remorse wear off.
Then, as they.
Eventually, scatter around the ship,
I would make a run to scavenge for water
primarily and food if possible,
and that wouldn't be our main concern.
We also have a computer with us,
which we can use for some sort of intel
and or to monitor procedures
happening on the ship to a degree.
So I say, let's make this plot of land
right in front of our marker,
our new base and slowly
but surely begin running around for supplies
over the next few days at this point.
This is Alice's best course of action
waking up cold, feeble and aimless.
She then goes to record her plight
onto a nearby computer flight log,
telling the world the truth of what happened
on the Ishimura, believing
that the marker is the cause of all of this,
and that whoever finds this message
needs to destroy the marker.
Alissa signs out and begins the sequence
to open the airlock doors
just as she runs for her
sweet life onto the ship,
right as the seal doors
begin to open and flood the room
with the cold vacuum emptiness of space,
ejecting every horror
from that room out, including Alissa herself
floating on the brim of 87th
orbit, slowly
succumbing to the silent screams of space.
Suddenly,
an incoming ship radios in on the Ishimura
hearing nothing but silence on the comps,
and it prepares to board the first vessel,
reigniting a new sequence of horrifying
events that are about to unfold yet again.
And if you don't like sexy space monsters
coming for your flesh like comment,
let us know what you like
and of course, didn't like.
Don't forget to check out how
to be playlist down below.